Гірськолижні курорти в Україні під час локдауну працюватимуть.
За словами головного санітарного лікаря Віктора Ляшка, це має розвантажити мегаполіси, а під час катання на лижах заразитися неможливо.
Якщо все так логічно і просто, чому тоді, приміром, Франція, Італія та Німеччина закрили підйомники на своїх альпійських курортах?
У ЄС побоюються, що буде "другий Ішгль".
Навесні цього року цей австрійський курорт став одним з найбільших розсадників коронавірусу в Європі.
У невеличкому селищі Ішгль з населенням трохи більше ніж півтори тисячі жителів було організоване бурхливе нічне життя для туристів.
У місцевих барах під час вечірок коронавірус швидко поширився і потім розлетівся по всій Європі,
включно з Норвегією та Ісландією, коли відпочивальники стали повертатися додому.
Нині ж у ЄС стурбовані, що робота гірськолижних курортів, куди знову захочуть потрапити туристи з усієї Європи,
просто зведе до нуля усі карантинні обмеження останніх місяців і що це може спричинити третю хвилю COVID-19.
Найбільша проблема - навіть не бари і ресторани на гірськолижних курортах.
Частину їх можна закрити, а решту зобов'язати працювати лише на свіжому повітрі або на винос.
Найбільше урядовців, зокрема французьких та німецьких, непокоїть людський фактор.
Адже молодь, яка приїхала б відпочити на різдвяні та новорічні свята, навряд чи
дисципліновано сидітиме вечорами в готельних номерах, а не "туситиме" у великій компанії.
Другий фактор - підйомники. Є побоювання, що все одно складно буде уникнути тут великого скупчення людей у щоденних чергах.
Утім, чимало людей вважають рішення влади закрити гірськолижні курорти "невиправданим".
На французьких курортах працівники галузі протестують, вимагаючи права працювати у святковий період.
Ми не розуміємо, як вони можуть пояснити нам, що в чергах на підйомники набагато більше ризиків,
ніж у паризькому метро. Метро накрите, всі всередині. А тут ми просто неба.
Формально гірськолижні курорти у Франції не закриті, але підйомники і готелі закриті, а також заборонена робота барів і ресторанів.
У деяких регіонах французьких Альп, де випав сніг, вже чимало людей.
Вони катаються на санях та бігових лижах.
Ці види активного дозвілля дозволені, щоб ті, хто має власні будинки чи квартири в горах,
могли поїхати туди, зокрема під час свят, і тим самим розвантажити великі міста в умовах пандемії.
Той самий аргумент, використовує й уряд України: хто може - геть з міста на природу.
Головна різниця в тому, що підйомники на українських гірськолижних курортах не закриватимуть під час локдауну.
Тож, найбільший гірськолижний курорт України "Буковель" має працювати на свята.
У деяких інтернет-ЗМІ стали писати, що це рішення пролобіювали люди з оточення олігарха Ігоря Коломойського.
Але нині йому належить лише невелика частка цього курорту, а більшість майна,
серед якого і 16 підйомників, перебувають на балансі "Приватбанку" після його націоналізації.
В українському уряді запевняють, що робота місць потенційного зараження, до яких належать і підйомники, буде суворо регламентована.
А ресторани та лазні на українських гірськолижних курортах не працюватимуть.
У сусідній з Україною Польщі підйомники теж поки працюють.
Лижники повинні дотримуватися дистанції та носити маску.
Обладнання, яке здається в оренду, ретельно дезінфікують.
А вітрове скло, прикріплене до сидячого підйомника, має бути підняте, щоб завжди було свіже повітря.
А от в Італії не можна поїхати в гори не лише, щоб покататися на лижах,
а навіть просто щоб подихати свіжим повітрям.
На різдвяні та новорічні свята діятиме заборона на переміщення між регіонами країни, щоб стримати поширення вірусу.
У сусідній Австрії підйомники працюватимуть фактично лише для самих австрійців.
Туристів майже не буде, адже готелі та ресторани залишатимуться закритими до 7 січня.
Крім того, всі, хто приїхав в Австрію із зон ризику, а це означає, що майже з усієї Європи, повинні спершу відбути десятиденний карантин.
У Німеччині гірськолижні курорти теж не працюють - частковий локдаун, який подовжили до 10 січня, поширюється і на підйомники.
В Альпах фактично єдина країна, де наразі відкрився гірськолижний сезон - це Швейцарія -
попри те, що кількість нових інфікувань тут продовжує швидко збільшуватися.
Тим не менше гірськолижники рішення влади підтримують.
Сподіваюся, що ми не пошкодуємо про це за три-чотири тижні.
Шлях, яким ми йдемо у Швейцарії, - це суміш особистої відповідальності та контролю.
Я думаю, що ми можемо з цим впоратися.
Люди повинні мати можливість рухатися. Це дуже важливо для всіх.
Схоже, українські любителі гірськолижного відпочинку дотримуються такої ж думки.
На Новий рік вільних місць на території комплексу "Буковель" вже немає,
а на кінець грудня-початок січня, як сказали DW у готелі, українці зараз активно бронюють.
У приватних садибах навколо курорту теж на брак замовлень не скаржаться і повним ходом готуються до святкового сезону.